since disgraced Trump national security
adviser Michael Flynn was forced to
resign from the Trump administration for
lying about his communications with
Russia we found out that he was also
lobbying on behalf of Turkey didn't tell
the State Department and after all of
this came out you may have been asking
yourself how is it possible that the
Trump team didn't know about this why
didn't they vet Michael Flynn multiple
people in the Trump administration have
been asked about this and they said we
just didn't know as it turns out they
did know both the White House and the
Trump transition team did a background
check on Flynn after Trump was elected
they found out about Flynn ties to
Turkey and they still appointed him
national security advisor NBC News
reported this on Friday night saying
they got the information from sources
close to the Trump Russia investigation
this suggests either that the Trump team
didn't think that Flynn's foreign ties
were a big deal or they didn't think
that anybody would find out and just
when I thought we had already hit rock
bottom on the blame Obama for everything
thing Trump and other White House
officials have now been going around
recently emphasizing that it was
actually Obama's administration that
originally gave Flynn his security
clearance so you know I guess it's
Obama's fault for all this take a look
at this clip the most recent one it
comes back to Mike Flynn who when he
last when he resigned you said that he
was treated horribly and that you felt
badly about that given what we now are
seeing on the payments from Turkey and
Russia would you stand by that comment
let me just say I do feel badly for him
he served the country he was a general
but just remember he was approved by the
Obama administration at the highest
level and when they say we didn't vet
well Obama I guess didn't vet because he
was approved at the highest level of
security by the Obama administration
this entire argument of oh the Flynn
stuff is Obama's fault it's all
predicated on the notion that the Trump
team didn't know about Flynn's
connections and Obama should have known
we have now learned that the Trump team
did know about Flynn's
so all of this blame Obama stuff about
Flynn it's even more deceptive than we
thought now that we know the Trump team
has been lying all along about what they
knew about Flint
that's exactly right now I also just
think that the Trump team thought that
they could get away with this because
advisors don't have to go to the Senate
for confirmation right so you know a
like a Steve Bannon was appointed to a
position that required Senate
confirmation there's no way that given
his past he would been confirmed Michael
Flynn the same thing I think you know
that scandal also started within the
administration itself
yeah the blame Obama scapegoat is almost
always nonsense but this time they've
actually been caught red-handed knowing
exactly what was going on with Flynn and
then they try to blame Obama for it
anyway
and by the way Obama fired Flynn I'm
actually thinking about extreme betting
is anybody else worried that the
administration of extreme betting either
failed to properly vet or vetted and
ignored the results of someone at the
most sensitive national security level
this could be really bad for the Trump
administration if and when all the facts
on the Russia investigation come out but
when I hear Trump talk about extreme
vetting and we think about the Flynn
thing I'm certainly not confident Pat
that extreme vetting is going to be the
Forte of the Trump administration right
it starts at the top right if you can't
do extreme betting for the people that
are working in your inner circle you
can't do it for the rest of the country
absolutely and the next frontier on
Flynn is that last week the House
Oversight Committee said Flynn might
have actually broken the law by doing
business with Russia and Turkey without
having told the military or the State
Department and he may have even been
told not to do so beforehand so it's
really not looking good for Flynn the
only question that remains for me is
whether the Trump administration will be
able to successfully sort of
compartmentalize the flensing and and
pretend that it doesn't touch any other
aspect of the Trump administration
remains to be seen you can talk about
this with our viewers and listeners on
our reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program is sponsored in part by texture
with the recent conversation in popular
culture about fake news and alternative
facts
in the news media it's important to know
where your news is coming from and
texture features some of the most
trustworthy and credible publications in
the world this includes everything from
The New Yorker and Time magazine the
Atlantic Vanity Fair it's a very very
long list and texture gives you access
not just to the magazines but to the
latest in investigative journalism the
latest in US politics and domestic and
international news the texture app
actually makes it easy for you to not
only read the magazines but also find
and enjoy articles that you want to read
with daily recommendations and
interactive features videos and so much
more texture is also completely
searchable so you can mark what you like
you can then check out back issues or
look at bonus video content all of these
really great features are normally $9.99
a month which is a great deal for over
200 magazine subscriptions but if you
sign up right now at texture comm slash
Pakman you get a 14-day free trial some
of the great magazines available are
Vanity Fair Rolling Stone Popular
Mechanics is one that I like New York
magazine the vegetarian Times has been
bookmarked by vegan producer Pat and you
can get a 14-day free trial with access
to all the magazines at texture comm
slash Pakman why subscribe to just a
couple of magazines when you can have
all of your favorites on your smartphone
or tablet all the time for way less
texture calm /pa que mas